let's get into audience questions for
the week first one hey David is social
status a zero-sum game
some of you might recognize this
question as one that has been sort of
floating around certain circles of the
internet I don't think that they even
really need to be named but I'm gonna
take the question seriously in addresses
so is social status a zero-sum game
first of all what's a zero-sum game you
kind of need to understand that in order
to really be able to talk about the
questions so a zero-sum game or a
zero-sum situation is one where the sum
of all outcomes is zero and usually that
applies in fixed resource situations in
reality not that many things are totally
zero-sum even when we consider them to
be zero-sum but let's give a couple of
examples okay a zero-sum game poker is a
good example ten players show up
everybody buys in with $25 the total pot
is 250 bucks right the winnings are
equal to the money put in let's ignore
that if you play at a casino the casino
takes a commission called a rake you you
hang you and nine friends get together
to play poker there's 250 dollars to be
won the total amount of winnings will be
250 dollars the total amount lost by all
players will be two hundred and fifty
dollars if one player ends up with the
the 250 bucks the other nine players
collectively lost 250 bucks and it is
zero-sum why because the resources are
limited
there is 250 dollars of winnings that's
the total resources the gains and losses
will equal out to zero nonzero sum
here's an example of a nonzero-sum
situation self-determination in society
okay imagine that there's two people in
society that can get jobs and there's
two jobs available airline pilot and
computer science technician if you put
the person who would rather be an
airline pilot into work as the computer
science technician and the person who
wants to be a computer science
technician works as an airline pilot
both will be in jobs they don't like and
that will have negative repercussions
society loses and both of those
individuals lose because they have not
really self determined their fate they
are both in jobs that they don't like
if you switch them and the person who
wants to be the airline pilot becomes
the airline pilot the person who wants
to be a computer science technician
works in computer science
they both experience gains and society
is better off when people are in jobs
that they like okay that means that it
is not zero-sum there is the the total
outcome of them switching jobs is
positive alright I think we have a
general understanding of zero-sum in
nonzero-sum so now we get to the
question is social status zero-sum the
immediate question we need to answer
would be whether there is a fixed
resource is there a fixed total amount
of social status meaning that when one
person gains social status someone else
necessarily loses social status and
unfortunately as with most of these
questions it kind of comes down to how
we define social status and I know that
right now it's very popular to make
extraordinarily black-and-white claims
about the world and society but the
answer kind of depends on what you're
talking about the highest social status
like imagine a list celebrities that
might be 0 some are close to it why well
there can really only be so many a-list
celebrities because if that number grows
too much they're no longer really as
exclusively positioned as a list
celebrity celebrities because there's so
many members right so it kind of dilutes
so maybe there is kind of a limited
amount a zero-sum nature to a list
social status but think outside of
celebrity culture for example social
status is immediately much less zero-sum
imagine like reputation within
communities or smaller groups like a
small business for example a business
with 10 employees is small enough that
if one employee starts performing
extraordinarily well in the eyes of the
boss they're increased social status
doesn't necessarily correlate
lost social status for the other
employees it's sort of a different
scenario it doesn't mean that the status
of the other employees necessarily
decreases which is the definition of
zero-sum there may be some element of it
the total amount of status may fluctuate
but it's not zero-sum the the other
element by the way is sort of that
status is contextual sort of like
concentric circles you might have status
in progressive media that doesn't
necessarily confer status in other areas
so that's another reason why at the sort
of macro level it doesn't seem as though
social status is zero-sum shockingly I
know that there will be people in the
audience who will get really angry with
me and disagree and I look forward to
hearing from you about that